>> Jesse: CELEBRITY MADNESS
HITTING A WHOLE NEW LEVEL WITH
THEIR LATEST ATTACKS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HERE IS A LATE-NIGHT TALK SHOW
HOST, SETH MEYERS.
>> TRUMP IS INCOHERENT AND
INCAPABLE OF TELLING THE TRUTH.
HE SHOULDN'T GET TO ADDRESS THE
NATION JUST TO REPEAT HIS
ALLIES.
IF HE CALLS NETWORKS ASKING FOR
AIRTIME, THEY SHOULD SAY...
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE DON'T
KNOW WHO THAT IS.
>> Jesse: ROBERT DE NIRO
CALLING TRUMP A "WHITE
SUPREMACIST" AND A REAL RACIST
WAS BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
ACTOR SAMUEL L. JACKSON JUMPING
ON THE BANDWAGON, TWEETING HIS
ENDORSEMENT OF CONGRESSWOMAN
RASHID TO LIEB'S USE OF EXTREME
PROFANITY TO DESCRIBE THE
PRESIDENT.
DANA, DO YOU KNOW --
ASSAULTS ON THE PRESENCE OF THE
NOTE STATES COMPARED TO
GEORGE W. BUSH.
>> Dana: WAS PRETTY BAD.
THEY DIDN'T CALL HIM A WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
BUT IT HAD TO DO WITH THE WAR.
THERE WAS A LOT OF ANGER AND
FRUSTRATION AFTER THE RECOUNT.
I'M NOT EXCUSING ANY OF IT.
>> Jesse: IT WAS POLICY
DRIVEN.
THE WAR AGITATED A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> Dana: THE THING FOR
GEORGE W. BUSH AS THEY SAID HE
WAS STUPID.
EVERYONE THOUGHT THEY WERE
SMARTER THAN HE WAS.
>> Jesse: TODAY THINK ABOUT IT
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> Dana: I'M SURE THEY DO.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ENAMORED WITH
HOLLYWOOD.
IF YOU ASKED ME WHO WOULD YOU
MOST WANT TO HAVE DINNER WITH
HIM I WOULDN'T CHOOSE SOMEONE
FROM HOLLYWOOD.
I DON'T WANT TO GET TO KNOW
THEM.
I DON'T THINK THAT WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY IS ALL THAT
INTERESTING.
ON THE WHITE SUPREMACIST PIECE
OR IN REPEATING THE EXPLETIVE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT LAST WEEK,
EACH WAS A RELAX OF ABILITY TO
THINK.
>> Jesse: GREG, DO YOU DISLIKE
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE FAVORITE
ACTORS, YOU LOVE THEIR MOVIES
BUT WHEN THEY TALK POLITICS, YOU
ARE LIKE OH, MY GOSH.
>> Greg: IT'S DISAPPOINTING.
IT TELLS YOU THE MOST OUTSPOKEN
NONE HOLLYWOOD THINK ALIKE
BECAUSE IT'S LOCKSTEP.
THE PEOPLE YOU DON'T HEAR FROM
YOU CAN ASSUME ARE CONSERVATIVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT TALKING.
DO YOUR POINT ABOUT BUSH, THIS
IS NOT NEW.
TRUMP JUST HAPPENS TO BE THE
LATEST TRIGGER AND ALL OF THIS
AND HE'S A PROXY FOR HALF THE
COUNTRY THAT HOLLYWOOD LOOKS
DOWN ON.
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP.
THEY DON'T LIKE HALF THE COUNTR
COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW WHO SHOULD SEND ROSES
EVERY DATED DONALD TRUMP?
GEORGE TAKAEI.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF HIS CAREER.
I DON'T REMEMBER HIM BEING IN
ANYTHING BUT IT IS HIS
TRUMP-TRIGGERED TWEETS AND ITS
BREATHE NEW LIFE INTO GEORGE
TAKEI.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE OWE IT TO
TRUMP BECAUSE THEY WERE NOWHERE
AND NOW THEY ARE SOMEWHERE.
>> Jesse: JUAN, DO YOU THINK
THESE KIND OF SLANDEROUS
STATEMENTS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, OUTRAGEOUS, THEY GET
ON FOX NEWS.
DO YOU THINK IT MAKES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS A WHOLE LOOK
BAD?
>> Juan: TO WHO?
I GUESS IT'S SUBJECTIVE.
>> Jesse: TWO AVERAGE
AMERICANS, INDEPENDENCE.
>> Juan: I DON'T APPROVE OF
THE PROFANE LANGUAGE, IF THAT'S
WHAT YOU MEAN.
I DON'T LIKE THE BULLYING.
I DON'T LIKE THE PERSONAL
ATTACKS THAT THE PRESIDENT
ENGAGES IN.
IMITATING THAT BEHAVIOR IS NOT
ATTRACTIVE TO ME.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ATTRACTIVE TO
MOST PEOPLE.
OBVIOUSLY SOME PEOPLE EXCUSE IT.
I WILL SAY I THINK THE BIG ISSUE
HERE IS NOT SOMEHOW THAT THERE
ARE HOLLYWOOD ELITES THAT PEOPLE
LIKE OR DON'T LIKE.
IT'S THAT PEOPLE SAY THIS
PRESIDENT THIGHS CONSTANTLY.
THE WORRY IS THAT TONIGHT HE'S
GOING TO TELL MARA LIASSON
PEOPLE GET FRUSTRATED AND ANGRY
AND USE PROFANITY.
I WOULD COME BACK TO THE ACTUAL
ISSUE.
LET'S STICK TO THE FACTS.
LET'S NOT MAKE UP STORIES IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY ACTIONS OF A
TYRANT.
>> Jesse: I THINK THAT
PRESIDENT WILL BE FACT-CHECKED
BY HIS OWN STAFF AND BY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
>> Greg: NEVER HAPPENED TO
OBAMA.
>> Jesse: I DON'T SEE THE
TYRANT ANALOGY BUT LET'S MOVE ON
TO EMILY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
CELEBRITIES, DO YOU THINK THEY
HAVE AS MUCH INFLUENCE AS THEY
USED TO?
>> Emily: DEFINITELY NOT.
THE YOUNGER GENERATION, A MUCH
MORE PROFOUND INFLUENCE IS
YOUTUBE AND INTERNET.
PEOPLE WHOSE NAMES WE WOULDN'T
RECOGNIZE.
>> Greg: GREG GUTFELD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: THE COMMENTS OF
HOLLYWOOD VERSUS TRUMP IS THE
HYPOCRISY.
IT'S RIDICULOUS TO ME FOR THIS
INSULAR COMMUNITY THAT HAS --
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES, THE HIGHEST
MEDIAN OF HOUSING, ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS.
THESE ARE THE GUYS SAYING THAT
THE GUY IN THE OVAL OFFICE IS
THE ONE PERPETUATING A POLARIZED
SOCIETY OR THAT HE'S THE ONE
THAT DOESN'T CARE ABOUT LOW
INCOME OR MINORITY COMMUNITIES.
ONE OF THE QUOTES WE READ BY
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ THAT
SAID G.O.P. LOST ENTITLEMENT TO
POLICING WOMEN'S BEHAVIOR A LONG
TIME AGO.
IN THIS REGARD, HOLLYWOOD STILL
HAS THAT HONOR?
BECAUSE WOMEN HAVE BEEN
RESPECTED ALL AROUND BY
HOLLYWOOD THIS ENTIRE TIME.
EVERY TIME A CELEBRITY OPENS
THEIR MOUTH WITH SUCH VITRIOL
THAT ISN'T POLICY-BASED.
>> Dana: THE QUESTION IF THEY
ARE MORE INFLUENTIAL.
I THINK THAT IF THEY WERE
INFLUENTIAL, HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD BE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: THE JAY Z AND
BEYONCE RALLY WOULD'VE PUT HER
OVER THE TOP.